Unknown: Good afternoon.
Welcome to pod two fifty six, number 99.
I knew that. Today is December 17.
It's fourteen hundred hours.
We should be broadcasting live from the Bitcoin Park
Twitter stream
and from
Riverside.
So join us there if you'd like to
comment.
I am joined this afternoon
by
the instigator of the bid acts,
Scott,
the man, the myth, the legend himself.
And
the
founder
of Exergy,
the next
multi billion dollar
multinational
corporation
bringing Bitcoin mining
to homes and to to chilly homes and offices.
Unknown: You sound like Rod.
Unknown: We have high aspirations for you. How are you guys doing?
Unknown: Chilling. Yeah.
Couldn't be better. Great.
Unknown: We're gonna do episode 100 on Christmas Eve.
Unknown: Yeah. You want to?
Unknown: I'm down. My gosh. Is that next Wednesday already? Yeah.
Wow. Wild. Yeah. We should do it.
Unknown: Hell yeah.
Iko, what were we just talking about? That I'm a dumbass idiot that thought he signed the petition and I might not have followed through, so we should probably update all of our listeners.
Unknown: So
You bring up a good point. We were just talking about the change.org
petition.
Mhmm. Take a look here.
Let's see.
I just wanna make sure I'm accurate and up to date with all these numbers. So currently, the petition says,
7,736
signatures.
The crazy part is that, like,
let me see if I can pull up
the
other stats
that'll
explain why I say crazy part.
Unknown: So
I thought I signed the petition change.org/bill
and chioni.
And when you sign it and enter an email and a name,
it gives you two big buttons that say donate
or share this. Right? Share on socials.
And I don't think I clicked either last time,
but hidden in the bottom, it's like another button that blends in with the background. It says skip, you know, just like just send me the confirmation email essentially.
And so I'm curious if a lot of people didn't do that follow through. Uh-oh.
Unknown: I didn't get a confirmation email.
Unknown: Yeah. It's it's kind of messed up.
Here's some stats. So
the
petition has generated
7,736
signatures so far.
It's been viewed
368,337
times. Wow.
So if you if you run the numbers on that,
that comes out to an aggregate
2.1%
conversion rate. Meaning for
every time people view this petition, only 2% of that 2.1% of them are actually following through and signing. And so to your point, Tyler,
the
kind of workflow
signer goes through when they're signing the petition is
a little
confusing.
Mhmm. Chain you know, change.org
requires
the signer to put in an email address.
And the way I understood it was that they would have to go to their inbox and click on the email they received from change.org
and confirm that they wanted to sign
in order for the signature to count.
And so there it's like there's two steps. You have to go to the website and sign, and then you have to go to your email and confirm that you want your signature
on there. And then that signature would count.
So,
you know, I've heard people say that, you know, they they never got a confirmation email.
Unknown: I didn't get that. I've
Unknown: seen where the email comes through, but there's not really like a confirmation link.
There's just kind of like a link where you can go back to the petition. But, like, nowhere in there does it, like, really tell you, like, okay. You're good to go. Here's your green check mark. You've signed. It's been counted. It's verified.
So it is a little bit confusing. And I I do have concerns that,
Tyler, like you expressed, you you go to the website,
you put in a name, an email address, and you think you're good to go, and you walk away and and take care of something else. All the while,
that is not getting counted as a signature as a valid signature for one reason or another.
Unknown: Yeah. I'm going through it again right now, and I still don't have a confirmation email. Tyler,
Unknown: did you get because I'm getting the email updates
from our man Enoch via change dot org. Oh, I'm not. Okay.
Unknown: I've been getting those, like, every day or so. Well, there's a button on my screen right now that says see news on the petition you signed.
Do I have to sign up for you're right. It should automatically.
Okay.
Yeah. This is confusing.
Unknown: Yeah. It's it's confusing to say the least.
So I mean, a couple of things. Alright. So
if any of our listeners are not aware, the petition we're talking about is for Samurai Wallet
to get
Bill and Keone a pardon from president Donald Trump.
Keone is scheduled to report to the Bureau of Prisons in two days to start his five year prison sentence.
Bill is scheduled to report to the Bureau of Prisons
shortly after the first of the year.
We are trying to get a 100,000 signatures on the petition to get this issue in front of Donald Trump
as part of a multipronged
strategy
to show broad support in the community.
Just a couple days ago,
there was a there was video footage of a live news broadcast from the White House where a reporter from decrypt media asked the president
if he was aware of the effort the campaign to pardon Samurai Wallet.
Donald Trump confirmed that he was aware of it, and he also said that he would be looking into it.
And he even flagged Pam Bondi, who apparently was standing in the room and, you know,
told her to make sure that they take a look at it.
So
one that tells me the the
all the noise and
everything people have been doing on social media, it is working. The message is getting out there. The signal is getting to where it needs to go, which is to the president's attention.
I mean, just the like, just hearing the president of The United States say
your friend's name
at a press conference
when you've been working
diligently to try and get the,
you know, the the signal out there.
That was awesome. Like, what we're doing is actually working, and it is making a difference. So that was just
very validating
to see that video footage.
So it is working. But,
you know, that's not to say that the fight is over. We absolutely need to be accelerating right now. That's just
validating and confirming that we have good momentum behind this campaign, but we 100% need to keep our
foot on the gas pedal and keep pushing forward.
Okay. So, like, that's the the petition we're talking about. So let's let's, like,
break down these petition details a little bit. First
and foremost,
you
do not need to put your legal name
on the petition.
There I have posted several times a change.org
link where change.org
explains
that
they respect the fact that some people want to keep their
their personal identity
separate from the causes that they support
and the petitions that they sign. So change.org says that it's okay to use a pseudonym. It's okay to use an alias. It's okay to use a pen name. You do not have to put your legal name on the petition. So for anyone who's concerned about
potentially doxing themselves or linking their real world identity to this cause, it is okay to use a pseudonym, and even change.org themselves say that.
As far as the email address goes,
there's
several services out there that provide disposable emails.
One that I've tested with change.org
petition myself is change
sorry, is
temp-email.org.
So I know that for sure that one works.
And I say that because there's some that don't work. For example, Gorilla Mail, I tested that one with change.org, and that doesn't work.
But temp-mail.com,
sorry, .org does work.
Okay. So there's the the name and email piece of it, your personal information piece of it. It is okay to use a pseudonym.
The next thing I wanna point out is what you brought up, Tyler.
Change.org
attempts to verify that actual people are signing the petition
even though they're not, like,
linking their their legal names. Right? So the mechanism change.org
has implemented to do that is an email verification
from what I understand.
You should be getting an email from change.org
after you sign
asking you to confirm that you want to sign.
From what I've seen,
it's not like there's this. It's not very clear, and it it's kind of confusing. But I would just encourage people to please check your emails after you sign
and
make sure you, at at the very least, click on the link that brings you back to change.org because I think that's the
the way that it determines that you've seen the email, you've opened it, and you're confirming that that is a valid email and that you are a human, you're not a bot.
So at the very least, do that. And and then it should be counted as a valid signature.
And the reason I'm saying that's important is because, like we were just talking about, there's been some,
almost 370,000
views
on that petition,
but only 2.1%
of those views have actually been converted into valid signatures.
I'd like to see that conversion rate a lot higher because we're going for a 100,000 signatures, and we've got a long ways to go.
The next thing I wanna tell you is that after you sign,
change.org
presents you with an option to make a donation. And the way they word it makes it sound like that donation is supporting
Bill and Keone. But
change.org
retains 100%
of all the donations that they receive. Zero of those dollars go back to
Bill and Kion or their families.
There is a separate fundraiser
through
givesendgo.com/billandkioni,
and that fundraiser
goes directly to the families
of the two developers. And the proceeds get split $50.50 between the two families.
So if you would like to make a financial contribution,
go to givesendgo.com/billandchioni,
and there you can,
make a fiat donation.
The
ability to donate in cryptocurrency
will come online
after
the developers surrender dates.
So this will be you know, Keone is surrendering in two days,
and Bill is surrendering,
after the first of the year. So it'll be after Bill is surrendered,
and both of them are in custody
off of bail,
then we will bring the cryptocurrency
donation options online.
Otherwise, we run the risk of them breaking their bail conditions and getting additional charges for obstruction of justice.
So we don't wanna do that. So we're gonna wait until after they're in custody so that there's no chance that this breaks their bail conditions.
And
that is
I think that's about all I wanted to say about the the petition itself. I've got plenty of other things to to say about the case in general and everything that's been going on, but
that's what we were talking about with the petition. And and those are the few points that I just wanted to make crystal clear for everybody.
Unknown: Yeah. Good overview. Go check,
make sure you followed through if you didn't get a confirm
email
so we can we can get that those numbers up.
Unknown: Yeah.
Yeah. Is there a way to check to see if you
are listed as signing it?
Unknown: I think I'd have to go in manually,
and look,
which I can do. But I think,
I I short answer is I don't think there's an easy way to do that. Okay.
Unknown: All the emails I've gotten from change.org since, they say this isn't,
you know, regarding
the petition that you signed.
So that's a good Oh, that's good. That's good. But I definitely getting the updates?
Unknown: What's that? Like, you've been getting the updates? Yeah. I've been getting updates, like,
Unknown: every other day or so from change.org
listed as from Enoch.
Okay. Good. And it says you signed at the bottom, but I definitely never got a confirmation email.
Unknown: Yeah. That's
troubling.
And
I'm not sure exactly what the answer is, but I, you know, I hope that your signatures count. Like, did you click on any links from any of the emails?
Unknown: There's not really any links to click on. It's it's more like news.
Unknown: Mhmm.
Unknown: Let's see what it says. Yeah. It's just like updates,
which I assume are
from
Enoch.
Yeah. It's like Twitter posts and things like that.
Unknown: I have one email from change.org that
the subject line is
Enoch Solsatame still needs you, which sounds like I have an action to take.
Then you click on the email and it says, thanks for signing.
Stand up for freedom. Pardon the innocent coders jailed for building privacy tools.
Take the next steps. Post to Facebook. Post to WhatsApp. Post to Twitter. So it's like
Unknown: Is there a link there to click on? There's links to share it,
Unknown: but there's not, like, a verification link. This is the only email I have from them. Right. Whoever engineered change.org is a genius when it comes to, like, keeping you involved in their system and
time spent with eyes on their shit because it's very confusing. Right.
Unknown: Yeah. It's
frustrating because we're trying to
actually
you know, help Yeah. These guys and and do something. And it it would be very
reassuring
to know
when
people have signed that that signature has been counted.
If anyone missed it,
a week or so ago,
Keone was doing Twitter Spaces,
and Ross
Ulbrich joined the Twitter Spaces, the first Twitter Spaces he's ever joined.
And he had a one on one with Keone for about five minutes.
And
one of the things Ross
told Kioni is that
the change.org
petition for Ross
was instrumental
in helping him secure his pardon.
So this is someone who has
been through it and been pardoned and lived to tell the tale, and he
is telling everyone
the change.org petition does make a difference. It is important. And I know it's it's very easy for people to look at a petition and be and just brush it off and say, that's not gonna make any change. You shouldn't be asking the state for permission. Blah blah blah blah blah.
Look.
Bill and Chione themselves
and even Ross Ulbrich has confirmed
the petitions are helping them. So if for no other reason, just go sign the petition because those guys are telling you it is helpful for them. So if you wanna help them, go and sign the petition,
which is change.org/billandchioni.
And another thing I wanna say is that regarding
those donations, why you should not be donating to change.org,
there's been $18,279
donated
to change.org.
So that little pop up that says to donate after you sign
has convinced
enough people to raise $18,000
thinking that that would go to the families.
And it doesn't go to the families. It doesn't help Bill and Chione. Change.org is keeping 100% of that money. They use it for what they call promotions.
This is change.org,
including this petition on their,
homepage
potentially, which I haven't seen it pop up there yet,
including it in their,
newsletter emails and
and wherever else they
are able to get eyes on the petition. Okay. But
sounds like it would be great to get the publicity. Right? But the the conversion rate is is absolutely abysmal.
Through the promotions,
there so the for $18,000,
people purchased for $18,000,
305,933
views.
Okay?
That translated into
signatures.
So for $18,000,
it equated to
signatures.
That is absolutely abysmal.
So the the money
is not doing
very good. That's like
two tenths of 1%, not even 1%.
Unknown: $200 a signature.
Unknown: Basically.
Yeah. $200
per signature. That and it that money is just getting lit on fire.
So, like, if you want your money to have impact, send it to the givesendgo.com/billandchionifundraiser.
That money goes to the families.
Unknown: So yeah. Like I said And ask your friends and family to
sign it. That doesn't cost any money. Right. Exactly.
Unknown: So, yeah, like I said, the you know, these promotions have resulted
in 305,000
views.
And in total,
the petition has had 368,000
views.
So if you subtract the 305,000
from the 368,000
and then do the math on, you know,
subtract the 900 promoted signatures from the 7,700
total signatures,
you know, you wind up getting closer to like a 12% conversion rate
from organic views coming from Twitter versus
paying $200
a signature to change.org.
So, like, please don't donate to change.org
that if you want your money to have any kind of impact, it would have a much more much more of an impact going to GiveSend go.
So, yeah, I just I wanted to say that too. Yeah. Well said.
Unknown: Alright.
Did you wanna dive into any other updates on the Samurai case while we're on the topic, Iko?
President was big. There was a lot of new podcast appearance appearances as well.
I've seen a lot of chatter. It's all over our feed, which is good.
Unknown: Yeah. The the media blitz is is having its intended effect. So I would encourage people to continue making noise, continue
liking,
retweeting,
quote tweeting,
sharing as much of this as you can.
Keoni has been on an absolute
rampage
of a media blitz the last couple weeks.
He's made appearances on television
and several major podcasting platforms
and several Twitter spaces with thousands of viewers and listeners.
So he has taken every opportunity that he has been presented with to get his message out there.
And in two days, he will be silenced
for five years. And so it's up to
everyone on the outside
to continue
spreading his message and being the voice
for him and Bill
to
make sure this stays persistent in the current administration's
span of attention and to get that pardon secured.
So it's more important than now
more important now than ever to be making noise about this.
And
I also wanna point out that I've noticed a couple of, like, really weird,
counter campaigns
going on,
that seem to be very well funded.
This seems to be
stemming from, like, Gavin Newsom.
And, you know, he I don't know if you saw it, but Gavin
Newsom publicity account on Twitter
posted a picture of Ross Albright with the, like, big stamp words felon across his chest,
trying to trying to to
paint the narrative that
president Donald Trump has been,
using his power to pardon people
to let criminals
who have done all these atrocious crimes,
out of prison.
And, you know, there's like a website,
that that Gavin Newsom posts links to
that goes through all of the crypto related
pardons
that
Trump has done. And I think there's a few in there that that don't even have anything to do with crypto.
But, like, CZ is in there, and Ross Ulbrich is in there.
And then, you know, there's this other media platform
I'm trying to think of, More Perfect Union
or something like that. I saw them do
what seemed to me like a like a very, like, well produced video. So like, they've got some money behind them. But they produce this, like, twelve minute video
explaining
the, you know, Trump pardons and these players from the crypto industry and and how they think it's all like a scam for president Trump and his family to make money and use the power of the pardon to
enrich themselves.
And so
and I and I've also seen just like a lot of really wild takes about the Samurai Wallet developers specifically,
and a lot of people trying to brush this off like they're criminals and they deserve what's going on. And so
it just seems to me like there's this this campaign for this counter
narrative
brewing
where,
you know, they're trying to, like, gloss over the fact that the SDNY
was weaponized and targeted these guys, and gloss over the fact that
Samurai Wallet did not break any crimes, and gloss over the fact that code is not crime,
and gloss over the fact that they made noncustodial
Bitcoin wallet software.
And
if there were any crimes committed with that software, it is on the users. It is not on the developers.
So like there's like very core
principles at the heart of this case
that
need to rise above the noise
and,
you know, stay persistent in the hearts and minds of everybody
who's watching and listening and receiving this content. So
yeah, that's
about all I wanted to say about that.
Unknown: I think there's one ironic piece of all this, not particularly
related to CUNY and Bill, but
you've done an awesome job, Iko,
getting the word out there,
helping spread the message,
posting about it, organizing
people to sign on change.org.
And when I saw that clip of Trump addressing
the situation in the Oval Office and he says he'll look into it, I don't know why. My first thought
was
such a private person, Econo Alchemist, is gonna have feds
scrolling through his ex account
to get the latest on this thing, and I just think that's funny that
the feds are gonna be looking at you, I think.
Unknown: I would not be surprised if I were on a number of lists already, so
I'm
not too worried about it. And
first and foremost,
broken any laws.
Secondly,
that doesn't even matter. If they wanted to shut me up, like, they would just make up some shit to use against me to shut me up and take me out take me out like they did to Samurai Wallet, you know. So like, I'm not
really concerned about it. You know? If, like, if they're gonna come after you, they're gonna come after you, and there's nothing you can do. So
but, yeah, I think to your point, yeah, you know, there's a lot of eyes.
I've been trying to like use the analytics in Twitter to
keep a pulse on things, and like over the last month,
my account has had over a million views,
which is great because I've been flooding my feed with
Samurai Wallet content. Yep. So
that's what it takes to
get the message across and, you know, keep it persistent in in people's
very short attention span.
Unknown: Shout out to the pod two fifty six
delegated FBI agent. Go sign the petition at change.org/billoncounty.
Unknown: Yeah.
Every signature counts.
All right, what should we talk about next gents?
Unknown: Well, I saw you had a bunch of good things on our prep doc there.
Unknown: Yeah, Scott, I'm curious
what that bit crane was that you posted a picture of. Looked like an s 19 chassis.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah. I think I've talked about it a little bit here before, but the the bit crane is a
it's a replacement for an s 19 control board.
It's the same size, has all the same connectors.
I guess with the exclusion of the ethernet connector and replaces that instead with a USB connector.
So the idea is that you could
completely run an s 19,
Antminer s 19 from
a computer.
Raspberry Pi,
you know, desktop, laptop, whatever.
So that computer would need to be running the mining like firmware. It's not even remotely a firmware in this case it's just an application.
Mugena would be a very good choice for this.
But,
yeah, I've made a bunch of updates to bit crane lately and I'm testing it on my desk. That was what that picture was.
Reverse engineering
a couple of different
protocols to communicate with Antminer.
What I've been working on today was the power supply.
I think it's it's gonna work really well. I think this will make a really cool demo. Hopefully, we're gonna run this at the Telehash
next
month
in at Bitcoin Park right before NEMs.
But
yeah. It's it'll be it's a really cool
tool for developing
mining applications firmware.
It'll also be a
cool thing for people doing
heat reuse stuff like if you wanna do a
it could be used for a single hash board heater,
water heater, you know, whatever. It just gives you a lot more flexibility
Notably in how easy it is to run your own firmware.
So you don't have to be
locked into
Bitmain stock firmware or one of the
proprietary
third party closed source
firmwares that are out there. Because we all know that those firmwares don't
really give you
a lot of options as far as modifying these machines to make them do what you want.
Notably is the if you wanna run it with a different power supply,
like direct DC or you wanna use the APW three, the s nine power supply,
you have to
you have to trick the firmware into
into thinking that the stock power supply is there,
which is kinda ridiculous. That's just a firmware thing so this,
will enable you to just
do what you want.
I have gotten mining working,
with it using a
sort of an older test firmware,
called Pyminer.
So it does work.
But
yeah, it's pretty cool and of course all published open source. I have the hardware schematics for the BitCrane,
on my GitHub.
And,
Ryan, the lead developer for Magena is incorporating
the
necessary code to support this into Magena which should be pretty rad.
Unknown: It's super cool because I think it's a great example to kind of rethink what a
a Bitcoin mining stack up really is because you're right in this sense,
the firmware is really just an application running on a computer. Yeah. And so it makes me think of like
my thermostat is the little application running on a tiny little microcontroller
computer.
The furnace that has a valve that burns gas
doesn't know anything about control. It's dumb.
It just does work. Right? And in that sense, like, the hash boards are more representative of that.
They just receive the appropriate commands and work and they do their job. But they don't have to have the the logic operations, the control, the application running on the physical device. It's kinda cool to rethink it. Yeah. Yeah. It is. This the BitCrane is very similar to the Adit board, of which I can see a nice stack of them behind,
Unknown: Eco there.
It's it's the same idea. It runs very similar firmware. It's you know, the edit board also lets you control
just a hash board, like a single hash board from
Mugena or whatever you want running on on a laptop
or Raspberry Pi.
But yeah, it's
it is kinda neat to think about like what you said, like the the hash board itself. It it basically just has a big
pile of these mining ASICs on it and they're not that hard to interface with.
So I hope that these tools will unlock a lot of cool things to do with hash boards which we know we can get for relatively cheap and they can be installed in,
you know, lots of different applications.
Unknown: Would Bitcoin ever be a part of
the stack up with
LibreBoard?
Or it kind of replaces the need for LibreBoard because you're running the Bugena firmware on a different device. Right? Is that the correct framing? Yeah. Yeah. It's sort of a different approach than
Unknown: LibreBoard. LibreBoard is is also a,
Antminer control board replacement,
but it it is a Raspberry Pi also. Right. So that would run Mugena on it directly and interface with the hash boards.
That's
gonna be an excellent tool for for using these things.
You know, if you wanna just kinda have one stand alone unit and, like,
program some, you know, your own separate control into it and have it kinda run standalone, think LibreBoard is gonna be a great way to do that.
Added board and bit crane are just kind of a different way of doing it.
You know, I could imagine hopefully, is what our demo at NEMs will be. It's like a couple s 19 setup, and instead of Ethernet going to them, we have USB going to them from a computer that could also be a node.
Then you can kinda hot plug them, and they'll start mining.
Unknown: Do you wanna run them with, 240
volt power on that demo, or do you wanna can you do one twenty?
Are you using different power supplies or
Unknown: Yeah. Could it
one twenty.
I I don't have two twenty in my office and I do have it like down in my garage. I have to like unplug the dryer.
So it's a pain in the ass to go down there and like be testing things in the garage.
So
I actually used Zach Bomsta's
120 volt unlock
hack Nice.
On my power supply. So I have a, like, a regular s 19 j pro that runs on a 120 volts. I can do it here on my desk. That's the Loki board?
No.
It's
actually a modification.
You open up the power supply Oh. And solder on two resistors. It's not that hard.
It's a little dicey opening up a high voltage power supply. You have to make sure that it's been unplugged for a while so the capacitors can discharge,
etcetera.
But
I
yeah. If you go to pivotal pivotal
pivotal Plebtech.
It's hard to say. Pivotal Plebtech
which is Zach Baumsta's
website.
He has a link to it. It's called the
volt unlock.
And yeah you just open it up and you solder on two, one mega ohm resistors, and he's got, you know, very good, very clear documentation on how to do this. The toughest part is probably scratching off the conformal coating on the PCB. You gotta scratch that off. Sold around these two resistors,
put it back together. Now all of a sudden, it works on a 120 volts like standard North With three hash boards?
Well, so there's a catch. So the power supply cannot output
the same amount of power.
Right? Normally, they're rated for like three, four thousand watts.
You can't
do that from a standard 15 amp 120 volts circuit.
So
you do have to be a little careful.
You probably can't put three hash boards in there and run it even at like stock hash rate. You do need to underclock it a bit. Mhmm.
But
you know, there are aftermarket firmwares out there that let you do that like stock bitmain firmware doesn't but
Mugena certainly would.
Nice. So, yeah, that's the catch there. I mean, you're not getting any
power for free.
And it actually makes it worse because
you need
more current at 120 volts than you would need at 220 volts to get the same amount of power.
Unknown: Right. So,
Unknown: yeah, it's a little bit of a hack.
You know, it's it's good for running underclocked units. It's it's good for running single hash boards.
Makes us, you know, have to, like, track down the APW three and hack it.
Unknown: You got a 400 amp service at the park, Hugo?
All ready to go? Absolutely not. No.
Unknown: We're working. There's one there's literally one outlet
that has 240
volt power that we can use for demos, and Schnitzel's bringing the hash tub.
Oh, wow. So he's gonna need that because that outlet is on the
this would be the Southwest
corner
of the Event Space Building.
And so usually, the hashtube is set up close to that corner
so he can use that outlet
to power the miner that's heating up the water.
So that's spoken for, but I'm gonna bring I have a small portable generator that can do 240
volts.
It can also do one twenty.
So either way, we'll be good. We might just have to jerry rig a cable to
plug in.
But I I made a cable for my Antminer when I was doing some tests earlier
this year, a couple months ago.
So I have a cable that's split into two female receptacles for
both cords
from an amp minor s 19.
Unknown: Yeah.
The c nineteens or whatever they are?
I just need to make sure that the the male plug that plugs into the generator is the right one. So that's the only thing I might need to change.
Unknown: Yeah. I guess, you know, I hadn't really thought about that, but we could probably just
do the 120 volt unlock hack on these miners and run them underclocked. I think they'll have the same
Unknown: effect. Because if we did that, we could just run an extension cord from an outlet, and I wouldn't need to to bring the generator at all.
So just something to think about, but either way, I'm good. Are you gonna be here, like, a day before the event,
do you think? Yeah.
Okay. So that
the day before the event, we can just iron out those little details.
Unknown: Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. I think we got some pretty cool demos planned for the for the telehash. This will be neat.
Unknown: Yeah. It should be fun. It's gonna be
the two fifty six foundation fundraiser,
our annual telehash on January 21,
which is the Wednesday
leading up to NEMS
twenty twenty six,
which starts on,
the twenty second and the twenty third. So that Thursday and Friday
is gonna be NEMS, the Nashville Energy and Mining Summit.
So
if you're in town or
around, make sure you stop by for that.
We're gonna try and get as much hash rate pointed to
our own instance of HydroPool
and showcase the work that we've done over the last year since we found that block at the first telehash.
And, you know, hopefully, we hit another block and get another
big round of funding going for
for keeping these projects moving forward. But,
we're doing everything we can to,
you know, button up these loose ends and make these projects presentable for the Telehash.
Unknown: Yes. So if any of our numerous listeners are thinking they wanna
donate Hashrate and haven't, quite figured out how to, you know, change all their, like, exahash
over
Mhmm.
You know, let us know. We'll help you get it sorted out for, for this telehash.
It's a pretty awesome event. It's pretty fun. It's like a whole day long event.
We're talking about cool stuff,
you know, talking with lots of cool people, showing off neat stuff, as well as trying to raise money to make more neat stuff.
Unknown: Yeah. We'll have all of the two fifty six Foundation developers there. So I think we're planning on doing about an hour
on stage with each of them to showcase each project.
So
we've done four projects.
we'll have all four of them share everything
they've got going on. And then there's gonna be a number of other surprise
guests to be announced
and fun things going on during the the whole event. So it should be a good way to kick off NIMs.
And,
you know, hopefully, can
raise some more money for open source Bitcoin mining development.
Unknown: Yes. Yes. This is the way.
I know what I saw
you had a Tyler, you had a hot water heater listed on there. This is like the perfect
kind of thing for an edit board or a bit crane.
I think it'll make projects like that, which you can talk about, but it'll make projects like that
just
significantly
easier to work on.
Unknown: Totally.
I yeah. Scott's referring to an image that was in the Heatpunk Telegram group.
Shout out to shot Josh.
It's like a single board s 19, half three d printed,
half metal case. There's a heat exchanger
strapped to it, zip ties, tubes.
It's crazy. Wi Fi dongle.
It's got components bursting out of it but all that matters is cold water goes in and hot water comes out. Yeah, man. Engineering It's like an RV water heater. Yeah.
Unknown: Proof I of
was hanging with gridless guys in, in Africa, in Mauritius,
and that's when they demoed the Juukali miner, which we talked about last time.
But,
they're pretty they're they're very like what's miner based.
Mhmm. So,
since then, some work has been underway to make a,
edit board,
that is compatible with the What'sMiner.
Awesome. Then we also need to reverse engineer that protocol
to add support to it to Mugena.
And so work is underway
to do that.
It's,
I've been staring at,
logic analyzer dumps of,
what's minor, communication
with the chips.
And,
yeah, I hope we can get that going. There's a bunch of people who are very interested in that. I think that'll unlock a bunch of,
machines that are kinda just sitting out there waiting for,
you know, some heat reuse or some monetizing excess solar generation.
Unknown: Do you have a Miner on hand or or is someone providing you with the dumps?
Unknown: Someone's providing me someone's
providing me with the dumps.
Trying to make sense of it. I I I do need to get one. I wanna get a
a complete What's Minor. I have a couple, like, random hash boards that people have given me,
but
without without the, like, stock control board and and firmware, it makes it a little more difficult. So I'm yeah. I'm trying to track down where to get one. I've got a bunch of, m 30 s and m 31 s.
Unknown: They're, like, 78 to 82 terahash units.
Really?
Yeah. Dude, they're just sitting here collecting dust, not doing anything. So Oh, man. Okay. Gold mine.
After the holidays. Let's Just Five of them are still brand new in the box. Haven't even been opened yet. Really? M 30 s?
Unknown: M 30 s? Yeah. Oh, yeah. I definitely want one. Sounds like a mining deal that went flawlessly.
Unknown: Yeah, I'm
pretty
good at
business.
Unknown: We have the same situation. We've got some M 30 s pluses in the basement that
had a very short life
and are now worth one tenth of what they were purchased for.
Unknown: Well 2021
was so exciting because
China
successfully
banned mining and the hash rate crashed.
And with an m 30 s, you could make, like, sixty to seventy dollars a day worth of Bitcoin for about $10 a day in electricity
Wow. At your house.
And it was just like the
the it was like the greatest thing ever. So, yeah, like,
when
that's going on,
you know, if you haven't been through an experience like that before, it's really easy to get carried away
and to,
you know, kind of become this, like,
Excel spreadsheet
warrior
that,
you know, forecasts
a lot of, like, really promising numbers.
And and then you put your money where your mouth is, and you wind up getting a pallet of miners that
end up never getting plugged in because you're an idiot and you didn't have the infrastructure in place first.
And then the
hash rate
goes right back to where it was, and then smashes through that and continues climbing up into the right, and then the value of Bitcoin
plummets.
It's getting wrecked is all sorts of fun.
Unknown: I think, you know, we we just had another chining mina ban, and the the hash rate is supposed to plummet. But Yeah. I would. The days of buying a stock machine and plugging it in
to any grid anywhere and making money are done. They're just Yeah. They're gone never to return.
Unknown: Right. But they're not even making it possible to fuck around anymore because all the miners are, like, 480 volts. Like, you're not even gonna really tinker in your with your dryer outlet anymore. You know? Like Right. There there's that and the
Unknown: potential that they're gonna start like putting secure elements on the hash boards Mhmm. So that like you can't
even operate the hash board unless it's talking to the stock
firmware and control board. Right?
Unknown: That would be
Unknown: wild. Is that is that total speculation, or did we just make that happen? About it a couple weeks ago.
Unknown: I wouldn't be surprised. It's a it's the direction a lot of tech is going.
Unknown: But wait. Can we break down this? What happened with the
what were you referring to about China banning mining again?
There was, like, a chart floating around
on Twitter. I believe it was Block Space Media had an article about it. Some, like, three gigawatts of capacity went offline.
Unknown: I'm pulling it up.
Computer computing power dropped by a 100 exahash
compared to yesterday.
They estimate 1.3
to 1.63
gigawatts
wind down.
Unknown: Okay. What's going on there?
Unknown: I don't know. Was there was is there any, like, official news out of the, like, CCP that, like, mining is banned again, or is this just, like, speculation that this happened because the hash rate dropped?
Unknown: It says that, yeah, the Chinese government instituted a province by province ban in 2021,
but they've got a system of favoritism.
It seems mostly, like, insider scoop speculation.
Okay. There's not a clear commentary on what what is actually happening
aside from the obvious, which is we saw a big dip in hash rate.
Unknown: There's this narrative that it has to do with Bitcoin miners transitioning
to
use their power to run AI
computers instead.
And I I think that narrative has got some
teeth on it. At least it it makes sense to me. Right? Like, especially for like public companies that are beholden to
maximizing value for their stockholders.
It makes sense that they would
I think so. That fiduciary duty to make money. And it's like Yeah. They they would use their resources to make as much money as possible. And if AI
hosting is paying more than Bitcoin mining, then, yeah, they're, like, almost obligated to do that. Right? Didn't Hut eight just sign some crazy deal with
Unknown: Google?
Unknown: Oh, I don't know.
Unknown: I thought I saw that.
Unknown: But yeah, I agree. I believe it, right? I mean, I think a big part of being a successful
AI data center is having a solid power purchase agreement and these guys are like, wait, we've got that.
We've got the transformers and things. You know, I think that the physical data center itself looks quite a bit different, but Right. You know, you can just get someone to build that.
If you've got the sort of power infrastructure
and the power purchase agreement,
then
Unknown: And they have proven
I think this is part of it too. The the the Bitcoin mining sites, the large operations have proven,
hey. We can do this, and it's it's kinda similar to your AI data centers. So,
you know, we're just another team that can do it. And I think there's a bottleneck there at actually commissioning these sites and bringing them online. So, yeah, Hut eight just partnered with Google to double its power capacity
across four new US sites
Over fifteen years,
$7,000,000,000
data center lease.
Unknown: Fifteen
years?
Fifteen year lease. Oh, lease. Okay. I thought you're saying it would take fifteen years to build the infrastructure.
But to that point, I saw an interesting thread about
Elon Musk and what he's doing with SpaceX.
And the way they were trying to explain this is like, you've got all these people trying to get these
AI data centers online,
and there's a bottleneck.
But what Elon is doing is,
like, bringing the
computing
capacity needed to outer space with those Starlink satellites.
So imagine that he launches
all these satellites up there, they connect to the already existing
network.
And
any extra resources on those satellites get used for
AI computing.
What?
Yeah. I should find I saw NVIDIA
Unknown: had a had like a
concept too for this
Unknown: data centers, AI centers in space. Apparently there's gonna be like a
new version of the Starlink satellite
that's equipped to
compute
AI
requests or, you know, crunch crunch
data for AI
with its idle resources.
And then same thing with the
the Tesla cars.
Like, if they're just sitting there charging
and not really using their resources for anything else,
apparently,
there's this idea that those resources
could, like, just receive requests for crunching AI data and and sending responses back. It sounds challenging with
Unknown: the Oracle problem because it's not an automated
network like Bitcoin. You plug in a miner and it just automatically starts hashing and doing what it's doing as long as you feed it work where you
have to issue
work and
orchestrate where it goes from a central authority
for AI compute,
whatever it is. Right? I mean, it's kind of interesting to think about that. I also wonder about, like, the the compute capability
Unknown: of,
like, excess compute capability of a satellite or a Tesla. Right? It's like,
yeah, they're they're pretty beefy computers in there and they could do some AI work, but,
like,
a data center has so many computers.
It it's just
I don't I don't know. The the hassle of
of,
sending the work out to all these sort of intermittent computing resources and getting the responses back and and orchestrating all that just seems like it's just not worth it to me. But
Unknown: I don't really know. It's much more like Blade Runner security state creepy to me to have all the
the AI hive mind, like, in the satellites that are watching over you, passing information in the cars all around you with cameras three sixty degrees. It's like Right. That's I
Unknown: heard that there's a Starlink satellites can actually provide network connectivity to other satellites.
Like if you wanna launch a satellite,
I don't think it's WiFi, but like you can like get internet connectivity at your satellite from
Starlink or other Starlink competitors.
That's kinda wild. That's wild. It's like the space win.
Unknown: Well and they've got like,
they're you know, unless they're in the shadow of the earth, like, they've got sunlight and
solar panels and,
you know, constant
energy
or abundant energy. Mhmm. Yeah.
I don't know. I think I think the idea sounds
interesting. But, yeah, Tyler, to your point, I think
the, like, Panopticon it creates, especially with the cars
because I know those Teslas have cameras on all sides of them. That is especially
unnerving for me. And then, Scott, to your point, the actual, like, feasibility of of it even, like, being worthwhile,
I think that's a very valid point and
good question.
Unknown: You're gonna start running these problems where it's like,
you know,
drives their car, you know, going to work and coming home from work at a certain time. You know, there's like that duck curve for solar. Right? Like, people have these tendencies to do things at the same time of day and now it's like, oh, like AI just doesn't work quite as well when
when everyone's driving or I
don't know. It seems like a huge hassle. I feel like
plopping these machines down in the middle of Texas where they have a fat power purchase agreement
is just gonna be so much easier.
Yeah. It's already hard, but it's gonna be significantly easier than trying to it in space. Like, come on. Like, space is so expensive.
Like,
the cost to launch
something into space is extremely high. Like, it's coming down thanks to SpaceX and doing significantly more launches, but it's still, like, space is very hard.
Then there's all the other
problems you have with
radiation and and having, like, hardened components
and, like, the fact that if it fails, like, you're just you're screwed. Like, you're not gonna
send someone out there on a scissor lift to, like, grab it and fix it like you would at a data center.
Unknown: Right.
Unknown: Same thing with a Tesla car, right? I mean, it's like,
you know, like, oh, like, it's just not working right. I don't know. I'm
skeptical.
Unknown: Well, SpaceX has quite the moat
with the Starlink business, you know. Hey. You wanna compete with us? Go build a orbital rocket launching company
Unknown: first. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, there are some competitors, but I don't think anyone's as Blue Origin just landed their New Glenn rocket.
Yeah. Oh, yeah?
I mean, they have like, what was it, like, 30,000
Unknown: satellites? It's a crazy mesh. Yeah. Yeah.
Unknown: I mean, that's a lot.
I've got a lot of them out there.
I wonder how long they stay in orbit for.
Unknown: Right. Before they disintegrate?
Unknown: Man, I I think they have the ability to position themselves, which helps.
But,
I worked on a CubeSat project,
and, so those are much smaller, and they can't position themselves. But they fell out of orbit in less than four years.
Unknown: Dang.
Unknown: Speaking of cars, I'm trying to find this headline
of,
they're they're trying to go after car manufacturers for not implementing
anti theft measures
in the cars.
And
so when the cars got stolen,
it's now the manufacturer's liability.
Unknown: That's no good.
No. But I know there's some new cars out there that had fingerprint sensors in them to save your user profile where you like your seat, your climate.
But I could see that kind of
functionality being used as an authentication
means.
Unknown: But the problem is
is that it's all, like, continue you're constantly internet connected too. Right? Mhmm. All cars for like the last like two decades
have been just
persistently internet connected. Sending data back,
you know, for your benefit and not
which is pretty scary.
Unknown: Okay. This comes from
New York
State Attorney General
James. Classic.
Yeah. Classic. Of course. Where else would it come from?
And the tweet says, we secured $9,000,000
from Hyundai and Kia for failing to protect their cars from theft.
Their reckless decision to forego basic anti theft measures led to car thefts with deadly consequences.
Now the companies must take measures to protect their vehicles from theft.
Alright. Can we talk about this? Well, Hyundai and Kia did,
Unknown: like, notoriously
make it super easy to steal their cars with a USB stick.
The Kia boys in Milwaukee kinda started this. And if you had certain model
vehicles,
Sonata,
Kia Rio, things like that. Anyways,
you could effectively just break a window, put a USB stick under the dash, and you drive away.
And so it became such a problem that
the insurance companies were denying coverage for these vehicles.
I had a friend who had one of these models and she could not get car insurance for it, so she had to sell it.
So this might be specific to like I don't know. Let's let's dive into it. Like, do you think about it from your standpoint?
It was a huge problem.
Unknown: Okay. So so say
my
my issue with that is where do you draw the line?
Because
it's like, you know, the famous cat and mouse game of
law enforcement
comes up with a way to detect or deter criminals.
Criminals come up with a way to,
you know, route around
those measures,
And then law enforcement comes up with another way to do it, and then they route you know, criminals come up with another way to route around that.
And it's just this constant back and forth game.
Unknown: There's still a crime in the loop. Like, someone still had to break the law to do it.
Unknown: Right. And so, like, you
know, where
So it was easy to, like, do that to Kias and stuff. But, like,
if
there's measures put in place, like, let's say there's, like, new federal guidelines. Like, if you wanna sell a car in The United States,
it's you know, congress passes a law that says the car has to meet these anti theft measures,
and those get implemented, and manufacturers start following those anti theft measures.
Eventually
criminals who want to steal cars are going to find ways to work around those anti theft measures.
And then when they do,
you're right back at square one.
And so like, I don't think that putting these
burdens on the manufacturer
solves the problem. The problem is people committing crimes.
Go after the people who are committing the crimes.
And, yeah, someone in the chat here is saying there's a big time analog here to Samurai Wallet. Yeah. And that's that's exactly right and why I'm bringing this up because it's it's not
much diff you know, a lot of people have been using cars specifically as an analogy when talking about Samurai Wallet and saying, like, look. If we're gonna hold software wallet developers accountable
for end user actions, then we might as well hold
the executives at Toyota
accountable
for someone driving a Camry through a crowd of protesters and committing a crime with the Camry? Why didn't Toyota
put in, like, crowd detection sensors
on the car to automatically shut it down and lock up the brakes when it detected a crowd was was nearby? Like,
do there It's a doom loop. Yeah. It is a doom loop. And it it's
it's
not on the manufacturers
to, like, be responsible for what people do with this stuff at like, once it's out there.
Unknown: And also, you know, it should be
people should be made aware of this like, oh, these these Hyundai's are super easy to steal like I wouldn't buy them. Right. Right? Like that's a like a consumer information kind of thing like
I'm not gonna buy one because it's gonna get stolen.
Unknown: Which will lower revenue for the company Yeah. Force them to
Unknown: rethink, iterate, and improve the product. They'll be motivated to fix this Yeah. For, you know, for their own, like, for the right reasons which is they wanna sell more cars.
Unknown: Hold on. Are you guys saying the free market fixes this?
Unknown: What's a free market?
I think it might fix this. Did we ever have one of those? What is that?
Unknown: On
Unknown: the flip side you know I was thinking about like how was like Target, know, they get these hacks and like a million people's personal information gets stolen.
Right? It's like, what the fuck Target? Like,
you just can't implement basic security like keep this stuff secure? I mean, I guess they shouldn't be collecting it in the first place. That's the fucked up part. But
Unknown: Right. Well, and even if they do, like, it's just a matter of time before
hackers figure out a way to to breach that database as well.
Unknown: But, you know, like, alright, so what if Target was held liable for the damages that was caused by getting their their database hacked? You know, maybe they'd be like, shit, maybe we shouldn't collect all this information.
Unknown: You would think you would think that would be the logical response like, hey, do do
we really need the person's name and phone number when they're buying a bag of dog food?
Unknown: Yeah. Right?
So maybe the food market fixes this too.
Unknown: Well, and it's not
far off from the Chinese
social credit system. I don't know how valid these claims are, but I've been seeing
stories circulate recently where like
Bob walks into Walmart,
leaves his cell phone at home,
brings cash,
pays for an item with cash,
gets home, receives an email
asking him to rate
the item that he just purchased or, like, complete a survey on it. Woah.
So, like, how the fuck did they just link
Bob to the item he purchased when he
when it wasn't through geolocation because he didn't have his phone on him, and it wasn't through the
electronic
transaction history connected to his bank account because he paid with cash.
So, like,
it has to be facial recognition. Right? And all the cameras that they have there.
Unknown: Shout out Palantir.
Unknown: Yeah. Is this all Palantir?
Unknown: Well, that's our version of it coming, cooking up.
Unknown: Yeah. That's freaky. Yeah. And it's not it's not run by the state. It's run by sort of,
you know, for profit by enterprises to
sell you more dog food.
Unknown: Mhmm.
Unknown: Yeah. It's sketchy. You know? I mean, I even find, like, instances,
like, in my own daily life. Like, I I take pretty
what I thought what I think are, like, pretty basic
privacy measures, like like having a degoogled Android device
using a VPN.
And
I've
seen,
like even in my own
technology stack,
like I have two
separate
mobile devices.
One of them
only connects through a VPN.
And I have
looked at things
on the web browser with that phone
and things that I absolutely have not looked at
with the other device.
And then
I received
a
email
advertisement
on my other device that did not look at this item.
And the
advertisement
came to a totally separate device and an email account that absolutely never touched the other device.
Was
completely out of the blue, and the timing was too close to me having looked at that other item on the phone to not be a coincidence
or sorry, to not be related. Right? Like, there's no way that it's a coincidence. That makes me go, what's the point of going GrapheneOS
Unknown: if like
they got me anyways?
Seems impossible.
Unknown: It's It's very
like,
is the leak in
my technology stack? Is it because both devices were on the same local WiFi network?
Like,
exactly was the
weak link that
connected these two? And if they're able to if advertisers
are able to see like, oh, okay.
Like,
okay. You wanna know what I'll I'll just it'll be easier for me to, like, tell this story if I just tell you guys what the thing is So I'm looking
I'm, like, trying to get as much media out there about the Samurai wallet case as I possibly can. Right? So one idea I had was like, well, a lot of people use TikTok. I'll make a TikTok account,
and I'll start uploading
the videos and content to TikTok.
So on my degoogle device
with the VPN,
I went and made a TikTok account and uploaded a few videos for the Samurai Wallet case.
Now on my completely
separate device that doesn't have anything whatsoever to do with Econo Alchemist or Twitter or TikTok
or anything else on that side of the spectrum,
on this totally separate device,
I received an email
to an email account that's never touched the other mobile device.
And the email was an advertisement for like, Hey, you should join TikTok.
Like
completely out of the blue, had never, like, even searched for TikTok or looked at anything TikTok related on this other device. Like, how the fuck did they link
those two devices, especially when it's a graphene device and I'm using a VPN like, the only link I can think of is that both mobile devices connected to the same
wireless network at the same time.
Unknown: Were you were you on cellular or on a Wi Fi? On Wi Fi.
Unknown: And so it makes me even like,
Unknown: extra So network sketched traffic to TikTok went through Yeah. The It makes me extra sketched out about interfacing
Unknown: with TikTok because it's like, woah, like did TikTok just like, somehow peer into all the
devices that are connected on my home network? And, like,
like, even if they did, how the fuck did they get the email address and know where to send that email to?
Unknown: Maybe that email address has been plugged into something and it also came to that same WiFi network. I mean, there's lots of other ways to sort of fingerprint you too. Didn't TikTok just get bought by like Oracle?
Unknown: Wouldn't surprise me. And Larry Page? I think it did. Wasn't that part of the deal to like,
Unknown: they were threatening to make TikTok illegal in The US and then they backed off? Yeah. But my point being is like, if it's part of Oracle, it's part of the mainframe where all data from
Earth
lives.
Like, every service stores their data with Oracle, don't they?
A lot do.
Unknown: Don't know. It could be a coincidence. It could be one of these crazy fingerprinting techniques. Right? They just paired something up. Hard to say what it is exactly. Maybe it's a number of things.
They probably send those
TikTok promotional emails out to lots of people.
Unknown: You probably need a whole new identity.
Unknown: And it goes back to my point about like being on like an FBI watch list or whatever.
Like dude, like the
techniques for fingerprinting and like the adversary you have to be like hardening your technology stack against. Like, if you think you're going to
protect yourself
from
federal prosecutors
who have unlimited resources,
I just I don't see it happening.
And that's not to say you shouldn't take any privacy measures because I think you absolutely should,
but it's just,
you know, if
you you should you should never, like, hesitate to say what's on your mind or speak the truth or stand up and talk about an issue. You should not let yourself be subjected to the chilling effects when developers are getting thrown in prison because
if they want to shut you up, like they're gonna do it no matter what anyways.
And so
you shouldn't let that stop you from saying what needs to be said.
Unknown: Yeah, right, that's a pretty good point. I mean,
that sounds like what's going on in this case, They're just trying to like market to you, but like Right, right. But yeah, I mean, it's like if they wanna take you down,
it's not gonna be a matter of like,
oh, these are the websites you visited or the things you bought. Right? They'll just like hold like a, you know, total sham court and throw you in jail for something or other. Right? Right. Right.
Unknown: It's kind of freeing in that sense, though, to to think that you're like, they already got me if they want, so I can say whatever I want.
Unknown: There's some freeing, like, aspect to that. I don't think there's any downside to it. You know, I think there's a lot of downside to not saying what's on your mind and and not speaking the truth and remaining silent.
You know? And I I think you you everyone should, like, stand up and use their voice and, you know, say what they wanna say because that's that's our God given right. And if you're not using that right and you're not defending that right, it sure as shit is gonna get eroded away
and taken from you.
Unknown: That's right. Slowly by Hyundai
and all the companies.
Unknown: Yeah. Ryan has a good point in the comments. Once again, I'm in awe of Satoshi's opsec. Like, how did this happen? How is there someone
that just is, like, untraceable
in in the face of so many people that are
motivated to figure it out?
Unknown: Yeah. I I I was gonna say the same thing as Pizzandy here. When it was 2008,
that that was very helpful.
Things were a lot different back then.
Unknown: I had a
roommate. This was probably, like, 2002
or so, and he worked for Safeway, which is a very large supermarket chain in,
I guess the Western half of the country.
And he worked there working on the the, he was doing like big data, collection stuff and he was working on all the data they were collecting
from people using the loyalty cards at the supermarket
and just trying to warehouse it all. So of course I was like, well,
what are you doing with it?
Are you doing anything interesting with all this data? You have where
people are, what they bought,
how frequently they bought it, what stores they visited, things like that. He's like, we're not doing anything with it. We haven't figured out what to do with it yet, we're just saving it all.
I thought that was kind of amazing, but yeah, that's that sort of like early two thousands things. Like they hadn't
really
figured out all these mischievous
things to do with it yet, but they were saving it. Which was smart.
And it's still there. Like twenty three years later, it's still sitting there. Yeah, it's still sitting there right, then come back through it. Now you hear those stories of people who like,
you know, get advertised
things for expecting mothers and they don't even know they're pregnant, that kind of stuff, right. They've certainly,
you know, through big data techniques and I'm sure now it's gotten even crazier with AI, right, being able to parse through large amount of data and make these connections.
Unknown: Big time.
Unknown: Dude, like the the last time I was in Colorado,
we went to
the
REI
recreational equipment outfitting store. Yeah. And they asked me like,
do you have an account? You know, as you're like checking out.
Because they do that like co op model. Right? And I'm like, I'm like, well, I used to have an account.
And they're like, well, let's see if we can look you up. Like, you know, give us the basic info, like name,
phone number, like whatever. So I give them some information. They look it up. They find my account, and the
last time I had made a purchase
was in 1998.
Unknown: Wow.
Unknown: And they still had that fucking information on me. Did you have any dividends?
I don't know. I'm I'm sure. Like
well, I think it's proportional to, like, what you spend. Yeah. I think so.
So, yeah, I like you know, if my last purchase was
twenty,
what, twenty seven years ago,
no. I don't I don't think I've got any dividends. But that is crazy. Right? So they're keeping it all. Dude, once you put that information out there, you can never ever get it back. That's the lesson.
Unknown: And they must have done multiple, like architecture
upgrades
to the data over that timeframe.
That is wild. Dude,
Unknown: you gotta be so careful with that information.
And even when you're like super careful with it, like, you still get a message from TikTok on a completely unrelated device and email account asking you to join.
Unknown: Yep.
That is crazy.
Alright. What else is going on? Do you guys see this
Heatbit Canvas?
Unknown: No. Tell me What about is this?
Unknown: So I got an email in my inbox because I subscribed to their newsletter,
and I've got a product from them before. I didn't see any tweets about it, so I hope I'm not jumping the gun here, but I also shared it in the Heapunk Telegram chat.
And Alex, the CEO of Heatbit, and one of the other
team members, Siri, chimed in, and we were talking about it. But, anyways, long story short is it is a 300 watt
wall mounted Bitcoin miner
that looks fanless.
I think there's a little circulator fan inside,
but they're calling it canvas because you can get different artwork on it. You can literally draw on it, paint on it, different surface finishes, but it's a radiant heater.
It's not relying on convective heat to heat the air. Oh, wow.
And for people curious about that, like,
radiant heat is kind of weird. It's literally it's not about heating up the room around you. It's about your body loses heat to cold surfaces. Like, when you sit next to a cold window, your body feels cold even though it's like technically the air is 70 degrees.
Right. And so when you're near a warm surface, your body's losing heat less fast.
So it's interesting. Like, you don't need a really powerful miner to heat up a whole room
if you're just sitting near these, like, wall plates.
They look like tiles.
Unknown: You will feel warmer. It's very cool. I'm looking at it on their website right now. This is wild. It's super wild. How like, what is a surface that becomes a radiant heater?
Or
yeah. Like, how do you make something a radiant heater versus
Unknown: So you heat it up. Emission grade aluminum.
Unknown: Yeah. This is this is actually like a a common misconception about boilers. Boilers, you've heard of radiant boilers,
radiant heat. It's it's
called radiant heat not because it's like liquid that doesn't make any sense.
It's called radiant heat because what it does is it literally just heats up the floor,
which becomes this giant, like, emissive
emotive surface. Okay. And your body sees a lot of the floor. So radiant heat is literally like
ray tracing in video games.
It's a it's all about view factors, like how much of your skin sees how much of the cold window versus how much of your skin
sees the warm ground.
That's how radiant heat works. It's very interesting.
And so if you can get more surface area warm, doesn't even have to be super hot, it has to be warmer than you. Your body will lose less heat.
Unknown: Wow. So so I you know, this is a Bitcoin miner. Right? So I see they have a lot of It's eight terahash. They have a lot of ASICs,
you know, touching this big radiant surface.
Unknown: Yeah. That's neat. Oh, I wanna It's make super cool idea.
Yeah. I can't wait to get my hands on one and check it out.
Unknown: It looks cool.
Unknown: It does.
Unknown: And it's silent.
Unknown: Yeah. There's kind of like a translucent photo on the website. It looks like there's some little blower fan in there, but it also looks like there's
copper heat sink pipes, like vapor chambers.
So I imagine
you have a small fan to help, but really it's just like
trying to get this ASIC heat to as much surface area, this big slab.
And then that's emitting heat to the room.
Unknown: Wow.
Unknown: Cool design. It's way more efficient than heating the air
because you can imagine like air leaks out through gaps in windowsills and door frames.
And so there's this notion in the heating industry that I've come to learn called air changes per hour. And it's effectively like, oh, shit. Cold air got back into the house. We have to reheat it.
Versus if you just get the house to all the surfaces to 70 degrees once, just have to keep them there. You don't have to like reheat them from scratch,
if that makes sense.
Unknown: So I'm curious. You said it's eight terahash. How big is this radiant surface?
Unknown: It looks like it's like like two feet by two feet roughly.
Unknown: Yeah. Like a big picture, like a big square
Okay. Picture you'd put on the wall. It says dimensions are 23.6
Unknown: inches high by 23 points. Alright. I was off by four tenths of an inch. Yeah. So two foot by two foot is a good guess. So that's that's
Unknown: you know, I don't know what ASIC chips they're using, but that's that has them pretty, you know, spread out. Or I guess they have heat pipes. So, you know but they're they're basically spreading out the heat over a much bigger surface for the heating power.
Right. Right? Because we have, you know, an Antminer isn't that an Antminer hash board isn't that big, and it's,
like, you know, 90 to a 100 terahash
and or a thousand watts.
Unknown: Right. Well, what's eight terahash at 300 watts? Like, what kind of chips might those be? Eight terahash, 300 watts?
Unknown: I don't know. I mean, if it's,
you know, if it were Bitmain ASICs, if it were BM 13 seventy's like out of the S21 Pro,
that would be like
eight.
Unknown: They're at 37.5.
Unknown: Oh, that's
That's like s 19. That's like j pro something.
Well, actually that's not even j pro.
Yeah. That'd be really really interesting to know. I know that they were looking into the the Bitmain chips and reusing them, but before that they used the Bitfury chips which Mhmm. Are real old.
Unknown: Well, it might not be apples to apples like
the power consumption at the wall
doesn't all go to driving the chips.
Unknown: Oh, you just divided the 300 watts by Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Right.
Yeah. They have fan in there, power supply loss, things like that.
Unknown: I think it's such a cool
form factor.
Unknown: Yeah. It looks neat. That is neat. Oh man. I wanna tear one down.
Unknown: Should make my bathroom
floor out of them. Oh.
Unknown: There we go. Yeah. So this is what we need. Right? Because
you can get electric electric
radiant heating. It's like a mat and you kinda roll it out underneath the tile or whatever in your floor and just like grow over it.
We need that but it's just like this mesh of ASICs that you just rolled out.
Unknown: That would be crazy. They
Unknown: do have that flexible
PCB material on JLC PCB.
Unknown: Yes.
Oh man.
Think the issue is that you need to get quite a bit more heat out of these chips, right, because
they can only withstand like,
I don't know, max max 90 C but obviously the surface temperature of a electric
coil is gonna be much hotter than that. Right.
Unknown: Yeah. That's actually what we had to dial our miner back for here for our radiant floor because we just did like a staple up job with PEX tubing, but
that Wutz Miner gets like a 160 degree water,
but you'll warp the subfloor. It's a 100 year old wood.
You don't really wanna be above one twenty for radiant floor. It's also just not comfortable for your feet if you have socks or no shoes on upstairs
on top of it. So
it's kind of interesting. Hot coals. Yeah.
Unknown: That is interesting.
Yeah. But you've got like
are they is it a water block on the hash boards, or is it it's a hydro?
Unknown: Yep. It's water blocks, hydros. Yeah. So you've got So it's like direct to chip cooling. Yeah. You can pull
Unknown: a lot of heat real fast off of those by running a bunch of water
through the water block. I
don't know how like, if you just took an ASIC chip and, like, encased it in
the the grout,
like, below tile, you know, would that remove enough would that be able to remove enough heat from the chip?
I
Unknown: don't know what Sounds like something Rev Hoddle will try.
Unknown: Yeah. Right? He did it with the
what was that type of clay called?
Unknown: He like The
cooling?
Unknown: Yeah. He like reversed the he used the heat from the miner to like cool down air
using this type of clay.
Unknown: I don't remember what the clay was called, but that was wild. Yeah.
Unknown: Guy's brilliant.
Unknown: He is.
Unknown: That's neat stuff. I mean,
I hope that I hope that by sort of
liberating the mining firmware and hardware stack that we can just encourage
so many more of these experiments and and future products.
Mhmm. Because trying to do that with
machines that are meant for on grid mining in a data center,
that stuff.
Unknown: Especially like going to market. Especially it
seems like it's not far off from
people
in
positions of power demanding that
Bitmain put some sort of safeguards in place to ensure that
no money laundering
or OFAC transactions
can occur or crypto scams
can occur with with their mining machines.
Unknown: Oh, man.
That whole yeah. That like probe into Bitmain.
Unknown: Oh, yeah. I mean that too. Any news on that front?
Unknown: I haven't heard any updates.
I don't know. You don't hear anything from these Chinese companies. Literally nothing.
Unknown: Yeah. I mean, to your point, Iko, like, the mining machines are very far removed from
the transactions.
Right? That that's the pool that deals with that. Yeah. The the thing making the the block templates.
You know, the mining machines,
they are very, very specific in that all they do is,
you know, run SHA two fifty six twice on this 80 byte
Unknown: header that comes into them. You know, if I were a federal prosecutor,
that sounds like a lot of word salad just to say you committed unlicensed money transaction right there, bud.
Unknown: Ico, you're not supposed to say that. Unrelated.
Unknown: Oh, I'm No. You're right. You're right. But I mean, dude, the world is, like, gone completely ape shit mad right now.
Unknown: Speaking of
non non Chinese mining companies and open source software, I'm getting a demo of Proto Fleet tomorrow. So I
at the launch back in August when we were all together, I they were accepting
applications for the beta program
starting day one, and I put in the application while we were all sitting in the pool. Yeah. Awesome. And I am finally gonna get a little demo and
hopefully be able to tinker with it come the new year. Great.
Unknown: Yeah. So you're be able to get what it's new?
Unknown: Well, the fleet is just the the management software, not not the rig miner.
So this one I'll certainly ask about that. Have.
Unknown: Yes. Okay.
Unknown: I'm curious what the requirements are to run it and what that looks like. Can I run it on our server,
in Proxmox,
or
I see a question from Pizandy? Are proto guys gonna be at the heapunk summit? I think so. Yep. We're we're working to confirm that,
which would be great to have them
on-site, especially if we have fleet
too that we can play around with
and hydro pool and all the fun stuff. Right? Just run it all.
Unknown: Yeah. I mean, we're
working day and night here to get everything prepared for
the telehash,
which is in January. So it certainly should be ready in February.
Unknown: Yeah. It's a lot of work Yeah. Planning events.
Unknown: I see a lot of
of component reels fed into your machine behind you there, Ico.
Unknown: Oh, yeah. What's the update there? Oh, yeah. It
Unknown: is loaded with components.
No real update since I did these
sorry. Let me
getting all tangled up here.
I showed you guys these
added boards. Yeah. Right?
So it was
really neat
going through the process and programming the machine to assemble these.
But, you know, after I assembled it, that's, like, where I started discovering all the problems I have in my process.
So
I've just kinda been dead in the water since last
basically
since last week, I think, when we did this podcast. I I think I was talking about the solder paste
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: That I had used. I did not use the right kind of solder paste for these things.
So, you know, you can't really tell on the camera view, but, like, on the little RP twenty forty chip, a lot of the pins are bridged together.
And I tried three times and, like, different
techniques in applying the solder, and I just could not get it,
to not bridge those pins.
And I'm chalking it up to
the
shitty solder paste that I bought off of Amazon.
So one of our friends who manufactures
made a recommendation on higher
quality
solder paste designed specifically for these kinds of electronic
applications,
and I'm waiting for that solder paste to get delivered
before I try this again because I've only got I've only got enough components left now to do two more of these boards, which would give me a 100 pieces altogether. So trying to conserve what I've got left.
Unknown: That is a pretty massive achievement, though. Let's just take a step back. Like, look at all those parts that you put on there.
That's crazy. There are so many parts on there. Like, some of them are just microscopic.
Unknown: Yeah. It is wild. And, like,
Unknown: you got them all put on there,
all in the right place,
you know, hopefully the right value is in the right place. But that's crazy. Like The
Unknown: yeah. So, like, you have to think, like, like, just that, like, the RP twenty forty, for example, that little chip with the Raspberry Pi symbol on it, like, you can see there one of the four corners has a dot in it. And so that dot needs to be oriented
in a certain position
on the circuit board, and that position may not be
the position that it comes in on the tape when it's fed into the machine. Mhmm. So for
each and every single component that you're picking out of the tape, you need to, like, program into the machine
what orientation
that component needs to have in order to sit on the pad
the correct way.
And that position may not be the position that it that it's fed in. So you need to, like, you need to know that if it's being fed in at 90 degrees, but it needs to be, you know, rotated
90 degrees. Well, you know, the machine already knows that it's being fed in 90 degrees, so you you have to tell it to be at zero.
And so you have to, like, go through and set make sure that offset is set for each of the components so they're all facing the the right direction.
You
have to, like, program,
you know, the exact coordinates where the machine is supposed to pick up the component from.
And it's not like you can just tell it, like, yeah, pick it up from Feeder 1, and it knows where to go to find I mean, it knows generally where Feeder 1 is, but you need to, like, go in and tell it the exact coordinates
down to two tenths of a millimeter sorry, down to one
one hundredth of a millimeter, two decimal places.
And then
you need to tell it how far down the work head needs to travel in order to grab the component.
So that changes with each component because they're all different heights.
And then you need to tell it the exact coordinates where it needs to go to place the component
and how far it needs to travel down to place the component on the circuit board.
So, I mean, just building the program
for the pick and place machine, you know, for me doing this for the first time is a multi day process.
And, yeah, it was amazing to, like, go through that and then actually have it like, like, the first time I saw the machine, like, actually pick up one of those teeny tiny little,
like,
capacitors, I was like, dude, there's no fucking way that nozzle is gonna grab that thing. It's like it looks like dust. Like, there's no but
it went it grabbed it. And I like, sure as shit. Like, it worked. I'm like, oh my god. This is amazing. So
yeah. I mean, just, like, seeing it all come together has been awesome.
So I do feel accomplished for that, but,
you know, I need to make money,
and
I I would just like it if this would work. So
I need to get this solder paste thing figured out and give it another go. I'm sure it's it's gonna take
Unknown: some, some fucking around to find out. Lots of fucking around. Right? Definitely.
It's not easy. I remember I I used to go with a board assembly shop, and they would just charge $1,200.
They're like, cool. You sent the Gerbers. You want some boards? There's a $1,200
setup fee on top of the, like, materials and labor cost.
Unknown: Yeah. I was thinking about, like, what I would charge somebody to do this. And I'm like, yeah. Like, $1,200
seems like very reasonable.
Like it's a lot, it's very tedious.
Unknown: Sounds so.
Unknown: Think for this one I had
placements
to program.
So it's a lot. You know? You're doing, like,
you know, you're doing
dude, there's, like, 10 different variables you have to come you have to program for each one of those placements.
So it's just it it
adds up. Like, it becomes very time consuming
very quickly.
Unknown: It's super rad, though.
Unknown: Yeah. So, I mean, just, you know, an update for anybody listening.
As soon as I get that new solder paste, I'm gonna try the other two added boards,
you know, tentatively.
If that works, I'll have those. And then my next project is the Ember one v five prototypes.
Great.
So
I'm hoping I get those knocked out and then the Libre board. So, like, if the solder paste works and I can just,
you know, get through that, then it should
shouldn't be more than, like, a week and a half or two weeks before I am, like, getting through the Ember one and the Libre board. So it's like as soon as I can just figure out this part of the process where I'm not
soldering pins together,
I'm like right there on being able to
crank this stuff out of the shop relatively quickly.
Unknown: Sweet.
Unknown: Yeah. I I feel like the
developing
that technique for spreading the paste on the boards, right, it's just
trial and error, right? Just you know, the paste is relatively cheap or at least the amount that it puts down on the board, right? Just like keep trying it until just all
the pads just look perfect little pillows on top of each one. Yeah.
Unknown: Yeah. It's a lot easier said than done. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. A lot easier. Don't know how you've done it by hand before but,
yeah there's technique to it for sure.
Unknown: That's cool. Well it's it's good progress man. This is
this
is a
going to be a key unlock for for building this stuff and getting,
you know, getting these parts out to Plebs because, you know, we make these designs and the first, you know, first post is like, cool. Where can I buy it? Right. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. I really wanna get to the point where I've got like complete
Unknown: Ember one units that like, it's got the hash boards, it's got the Libre board, it's like in enclosure,
it's got the heat sink, it's got the fan, it's got the power supply.
Like the like that Nerd QX plus plus I received, like, it had it's in this nice packaging. It had everything you needed to just plug and play. Like, I wanna get to the point where I've got plug and play units ready to fly off the shelf.
And, Ryan, to your question, yes. My pick and place machine
has a camera that's looking upward toward the work head. And so after it picks up each component,
it goes
and brings it to the camera,
and that camera will tell it the, like, offset
of, like, a perfect
crosshair
based on the
orientation of the table,
and then it'll, like, use that offset to figure out how far the work head needs to rotate before it places that component down. And
so, I mean, this thing just like it just it's like you
do all this programming, you know, by hand, tediously,
like, for, like, two, three days in a row, and then you you hit go. And it it literally runs it like a like any other piece of software, like a script, and the machine just goes boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom Just like,
pin one
markings. No. It can't see pin one markings. That's why I have to tell it what the rotation needs to be. So,
like, the machine knows the
the
components are coming in at 90 degrees.
And so if,
like, the
pin one is, like, toward the bottom,
then I need to tell it to, like,
rotate
you know, it knows it's coming in at 90, so it would be like it would need to rotate from, like, 90 to zero and then zero to negative 90 and negative 90 to one eighty.
So, like, I can or from 90 to one eighty, either way.
Like so I can tell it, like, how much it needs to rotate.
So, basically, it just looks at the component and says, okay. Like, I know this needs to be
at a 180 degrees,
and it'll, like, calculate the offset from, like, zero and then say, like, okay. So I need to rotate, like, say, like, a 185 degrees, and then it'll be at one eighty if it had, a five degree offset from where it was picked up. I don't know how you'd program it in but some
Unknown: chips,
the Intel chips actually have a pin one marking on the underside.
Oh, interesting. I don't know. That
seems like it'd be complicated to program
it in to recognize that. So
Unknown: this is like a marking on the component that tells the machine which way it's pointing?
Unknown: Well, normally, it's on the top. There's like a little dot or something to indicate what which corner of like a square chip
Yep. Is pin one. And so
what he goes saying is like the camera which comes up from below can't see that normally. Right. You just have to you have to stay. They're all coming in like this and I want them like this on the board so it can rotate it.
But, yeah, some chips
it's not super common, but some chips do have some indication whether it's like a differently shaped pad or some little marking on the bottom to indicate what pin one is.
Unknown: I'm sure there's pick and dude, some of these pick and place machines are like a million dollars apiece and they like take up an entire factory floor.
Unknown: And Yeah. This is amazing to learn about. And some company specializes in just making these machines, is so
wild. Yep. What a cool learning experience.
Unknown: This is your job, dude. And Ryan, since you're here, I did get a response back from the company that makes this. They do have
prototyping
rails
that I can mount to the pickup area.
They're not the same ones that you shared with me
in that chat.
They're different. They're even better
because they're made out of aluminum,
and they, like, bolt into the machine. So they're, like, very secure, and they won't move once I put them in place.
But, yeah, I'm gonna get some of those
for prototyping.
But, yeah, it is it is my job now.
Unknown: So That'd be cool to be able to
get set up to do prototypes. Right? I mean, it's classically hard to do prototypes because it essentially is like has the same setup time.
Mhmm. And then you just make, like, a couple boards,
and then have to do it again. But, yeah, figuring out how to prototype quickly is pretty cool. Right.
Unknown: Well, I mean, if if I got the right tools, it should, you know, just be that much easier. And
the guys at the at NEODEN, the ones who make made this machine, they they sent me some pictures of what they've got, and it looks it looks great.
Unknown: So does it it has to,
like the because if the if it's not feeding in the tape, now the pickup head has to just sort of increment down the line to get each new one.
Unknown: And you have to peel off all the the
Unknown: plastic
on top ahead of time?
Unknown: Wait. Say that again?
Unknown: With these with these prototype using cut tape rails,
do you have to peel off all the plastic ahead of time?
Yeah. Oh, no. That's sketchy.
Unknown: Yeah. I know. Because it there's no, yeah, there's no, like, automatic peeler when you're prototyping
to peel it off for you. So, like, in this setup, the way I have it set up, yeah, there's the feeder on bottom, which is, like, pulling the tape into the machine to put the new component in place. And then on top, there's a peeler that's also pulling back the tape at the same time.
So the component
is safe and secure in the real tape all the way up until, like, right before it's loaded into position to get picked,
which is perfect. But when you're prototyping,
yeah, you gotta peel
the tape off. Now the nice thing about the rails that I'm gonna get
are that they're gonna be bolted to the
machine. So they they should be more secure, but, yes, there is still risk of if I drop my phone into the pickup bed like I did last time, yeah, there's still risk that I could screw something up.
So I'm gonna bring my headlamp instead
and not put myself in that situation.
But,
yeah, you when you're prototyping,
you you can program the machine and tell it
you tell it where the first component is at,
and then you
tell it how many
components there are in the strip of tape,
and then you tell it where the last component is at. Okay.
And it'll, like, it'll, like, figure out the rest and and
pick up all the pieces.
Unknown: Well, if it were easy, everyone would do it. So Yeah. Truth.
Unknown: But everyone will be happy to buy their hardware
manufactured right there.
Unknown: Yeah. I hope so. I mean, as long as it's, you know, good
hardware that that works. So if, you know, if I can do that,
that's probably 90% of the battle right there.
Unknown: And then you gotta test it. Make sure it works good. But Yeah. Exactly.
Unknown: Help with that.
Thank you. You've I've you there the you've got components in the mail.
Awesome. Yeah. I'm looking at Oh, shit. That reminds me. I forgot to send you okay. So I sent Scott one of these Mhmm. Boards so he can try and salvage it. I forgot to send you the
the header
that needs to get soldered on here still. Oh, I've got some of those.
Unknown: Okay. I ordered a big bag a while back.
Cool. Yeah. Cool. I'm looking forward to to trying that out. The added board's pretty cool. I think it's really neat to see just, you know, a USB connector on a hash board and know that you can interface to it, like, from any computer. I don't know. I think that's really fun.
Unknown: Is the added board necessary
to get, you know, what's minor s potentially,
what's minor s 19 hash board to talk to LibreBoard
instead of just making, like, the the right cable adapter?
Am I understanding this correctly?
Unknown: We made the decision with the LibreBoard to put USB connectors on it so it'd be more. So, yeah, you would need to use
a ADDIT board if you wanted to use an Antminer hash board. If you wanna use an Ember one with the Libre board, which is kind of the
the sort of system we're working for, then, yeah, the Ember one already has USB on it. It's just you need a USB cable. I guess my question is is the ADDIT board more complex than just routing wires?
Unknown: Is there actually any
anything special going on on it, or is it just literally converting USB
pin outs to
Unknown: that plug connector for an s 19? Yeah. It's it's more complicated than that because Gotcha. It's it's got a USB to serial converter
on it Mhmm.
Which is that that chip that Eco showed that has the Raspberry Pi logo on it. It's it's running some firmware on there. Gotcha. That converts
Spyware. The because there's actually like,
you know, if you look at that Bitmain
hash board data connector, it's got like 20 pins on it or something like that. So there's a few different things going on there that we need to support.
Unknown: Gotcha.
Unknown: There's like an enable pin and there's I two c to talk to the temperature sensors and there is serial to talk to the a six and there's
a couple other
little things on there which which we handle.
So, yeah, it's a little bit more complicated than that. But I guess the good news is making an edit board for a Watts minor is not a big change. It is a change, but it shouldn't
be too hard.
Unknown: Yeah. That's huge because that's that's a great way to recycle these old cheap hashboards. Right? And give them new features, new functionality,
Unknown: new form factors. Yeah. Think so. I think so. Especially with the added board because that just deals with the hashboard. The the Big Crane also,
it can do three hashboards, but it also deals with the power supply and the fans. But, you know, in a really cool custom setup, you might not have the stock fans and power supply. So you don't you don't need all that extra stuff.
Yeah. It makes me think of immersion tanks without miners inside of them, just literally hash boards inside of them. Yeah. Right. Oh, man. That'd be so neat. You could just imagine all these rails, you know, that like like a big version of an s 19 case where they just all slot in there. Yeah. You know, you still gotta get the power to the hash board. Right. But,
you know, that's also could be done with rails along the top or Exactly. Yeah. Screw in sort of like cables.
Oh, it's so rad. Yeah. Yeah. It's pretty neat.
It's fun to screw around with. That's for sure. I bet.
So I saw
go ahead.
Were you gonna say echo? No. No. No. Go ahead. Oh, saw you had a
in the notes, Tyler, had a about this this mining pool scam thing.
Unknown: Yeah. I wanted you to elaborate on that tweet you had.
Unknown: So this this came out of the OSMU Discord, but some people noticed that there were pools
that one of them,
it was not
so, you know, if you're solo mining, you usually put in your address as your username
and then the idea is that that's gonna be included as the coin base to pay out the block reward to you.
Well, someone noticed that
their address wasn't in there.
So this was just a straight up scam pool.
They weren't gonna pay out to you. They actually also noticed
that
it wasn't even mining on the Bitcoin blockchain.
It was mining some share coin. So this was advertised as a Bitcoin solo mining pool.
Wow. And they had this whole webpage, you know, saying their hash rate was like
hundreds of petahash and,
you know, it's a Bitcoin solo mining pool, but it was it was Bitcoin Cash and
your Coinbase was not included
in, the payout address. So it was just a straight up scam.
Unknown: Dude, can you name names?
Unknown: I think it was like zpool
and
oh my gosh.
I'm blanking on the names. See, I think maybe I have it in my tweet here. I wonder how big their percentage of the hash rate was,
Unknown: Like getting Bitcoin
miners to point to Bitcoin Cash.
Unknown: They Who knows? They were well,
they claimed they had a lot of hash rate.
Unknown: Yeah. But But now you can't trust anything they're saying.
Unknown: Because there's these websites that'll like track like what the hash rate is of all these pools but
they're not I think it's just self reported so you can just say whatever you want. Trust me bro. Yeah trust me bro.
So this this tool that I made kinda came out of that discussion, and I it was kinda neat. I just vibe coded it. But,
you know, one of the neat things about Bitcoin mining is that
the pool sends you the work. And
you can you can look at that work that they send you and verify what you're mining.
And you can verify that your payout address is included in there and how much they will pay you out. So there was another,
thing that came up, recently,
where
there's this,
solar pool software
that was based on top of CK Pool called there was a Solar Pool called Bassin,
and it's it's on Umbral. It's like a single click install so you can solo mine to your your Umbral machine.
And at some point, it had been recompiled using someone else's, like, version of CK Pool.
And it was the the version of CK Pool was called PinkySwire.
Uh-oh. But whoever did this, it's not clear if it was Umbral or it was Basten. Someone someone changed to this new CK Pool docker image that they were using to build this app for Umbral.
And
it
from someone looking at the the work that the pool was sending them,
the pool it was sending the majority of
the Block reward to someone else.
So,
you know, they say like, oh, it takes like a, you know, a 1% fee. Well, no. That's not what was happening. It was significantly more of the Coinbase reward. So if anyone had actually sold mine to Block,
they would only get a small part of that Block reward, and the majority of it would be sent to some other address that was just hard coded in there.
Unknown: That's so messed up. It's so messed up.
Unknown: The good news is that we can verify these things. It's it's it's
very easy to look at the work the pool sends you and see
what percentage
of that block reward is going to who and where.
And so that's what that pool checker software does. It breaks down, you know, the coin base and what transactions are in there and, like, how much you know, what number of Bitcoin is sent to each address.
And we're actually adding this to AxeOS
for
for the Bidax. So you'll be able to see on the Bidax dashboard. If you're solo mining, you'll be able to see the Coinbase and what addresses are getting,
you know, which amount of Bitcoin.
So that'll that'll totally streamline this.
Unknown: Has Umbral made any comments about that?
Unknown: Umbral fixed it right away.
They Okay. Good. They were on it. Good. I don't know if anyone like really
owned up to
like how this happened,
but you know, to umbral's credit, they fixed it right away.
The developer of Bass and Cool was was pretty distraught about this.
I think he was
he felt really, really bad. Obviously, it's that's a blender. But,
you know, to his credit, he he was on it right away, but
and reported it to Umbral, they fixed it, like, within, like, an hour.
Wow. Good. Which is awesome. Know, it still relies on people who need to update that
app on their Umbral systems if they're running it.
But,
you know, we we also could see that the address of the person, you know, whoever's trying to hijack the Bitcoins and they hadn't received any, so that's good.
Good. At least not to that address. Yeah. Yeah. Right. At least not to that address.
So, yeah. It's a wild world out there, but luckily we can we can there's ways you can verify these things.
You know, if you're solo mining. If you're pool mining,
you can't. Right? Because if you're pool mining,
your address is not going to be in the coin base. It's gonna be the pool's address. And so then it's you just have to trust them,
what they're gonna do with that.
And that's
I don't know if we have a good way around that right now.
You know, the the idea with HydroPool is to sort of break it up so that it can be smaller groups so you you can just place your trust in someone that you you do trust.
Unknown: Well and the
API to get the the shares the pool is validated.
Unknown: Right.
Unknown: So like any user could just plug into that API
with their HydroPool host, and then they can just like collect all the shares that the pool is validated.
And, you know, they can store that for
eternity if they want to, and they can use it to run whatever sort of validation test they want to ensure that the HydroPool instance operator
that they're connected to is being an honest
Unknown: provider. It's still up to the pool to actually pay out based on those shares.
So there's some trust needed for that. But,
you know, this this sort of minimizes it. Least, you know, that they're I see. I see. Yeah. Their share accounting is
is correct.
And then, you know,
I guess with pool mining, the payouts aren't as large. So if they rug you once, then you're like,
you just bounce on that pool.
Unknown: Right.
Yeah. Like, if you only lost, like, you know, 10,000 sats for a day of mining or whatever. Right.
Unknown: Yeah. Right.
That's that's sort of Ocean's main argument
or justification
for their closed source
share accounting mechanism is that like
if we rugged people no one would come back.
I don't know. That's weak. Yeah. It is kinda weak especially because they claim that
they're like a decentralized
mining pool which is
incorrect. I mean, they're they are a decentralizing
pool in that they're an alternative to other pools but they are not decentralized.
Unknown: Right. Because Yeah. I have
taken issue with their marketing
pretty much from day one.
Unknown: Yeah.
Yeah. You're right. I mean,
I feel like I didn't but now,
I don't know, maybe now that I'm seeing more of their marketing, I'm like this is this is just bullshit. Like Yeah. I don't know what you guys are talking about.
Unknown: Right. Yeah.
Unknown: Luke seems to think that if their pool has
90% of the network hash rate that that's okay,
which is really not a good sign because if they ever got anywhere close to that you don't want them thinking that's okay.
Right.
Because it's not. There there is one company, there is a select group of individuals that control that entire closed source pool,
and, that's
not a good thing. Nope.
Unknown: I agree a 100%.
Even when
even when I did have my minors on,
I was
using Ocean though
strictly because even though I, like, vehemently
disagree with their marketing,
They
are you know, unless you're solo mining, they're, like, the only PPL and S pool
Mhmm.
That
isn't
contributing
to this full pay per share
scam, which I see as an even greater centralizing force that
is very problematic.
In fact, it was so problematic that I was like, dude, I just if I'm gonna be running these miners, I do not wanna be contributing to this full pay per share
problem.
And
I've,
you know, really don't like Ocean's marketing,
and I don't agree with it. But,
you know, they are a convenient PPL and S option, so
that's why I had my miners pointed there.
Yeah. I mean That was before
Parasite Pool
spun up and was, you know, available. Otherwise, I probably would have just done that.
It is decentralizing.
Right? That was the initial sort of excitement, right, is that it's a a viable pool that's not
Unknown: one of the incumbents. So that is decentralizing.
Anytime we get another pool, it is decentralizing.
Unknown: Yeah. I mean, I would say that, you know, they're they're making steps toward decentralization,
but they're not, like, solving the issue of centralization
in in what they've created.
Unknown: It is kinda interesting. You can. If you're mining if you, you know, connect to BitX or whatever to,
to Ocean Pool,
you can then take the work that they send you and put it into PoolChecker,
and you can see all the addresses that they're paying out in that Coinbase.
And
yours is not going to be in there.
Unknown: Right.
So Unless you you've got a ton of Hashrate. Unless you've got a ton of Hashrate. But,
Unknown: I mean, when you first start mining with them, no matter how much hashrate you have, it's not your address is not gonna be in there. Yeah. Right. Right.
Then that's kinda gets into the trust me, bro, that at some point it will be in there and that the the payout percentage will be correct.
Yep.
Hope so.
Unknown: And hopefully, continue the
decentralizing
trend that direction.
We're using I'm using their beta, and I can verify shares with their API, but I know it's not public yet. So No. That's I just wanna make that caveat that
it's on the roadmap, it works,
but it's not publicly available
Unknown: at the time. That is definitely a good step.
Unknown: Yeah. I mean, in my opinion, I think they've kind of worked themselves into a corner where like
Datum and I would even argue SV two,
they're,
in my opinion, like, just two different approaches to the same thing where they're enabling
miners to select the transactions,
but the pool is still controlling the coin base.
And therefore,
the pool is able to make decisions about whether or not they want to compensate
minors for the submitted shares,
and even how much they wanna compensate them for. And so,
you know, I think anyone,
you know, doing that, Ocean,
they I think they're kind of working themselves into a corner where, like, you can only go toward decentralization
so much with that model.
And it's gonna take something like a p to pool v two
with a share chain
to actually have significant
decentralization
effects.
So I think I think that is the next step. I I think there's there's limits to how decentralized you're really gonna be able to get with s v two and Datum.
Unknown: I think that's right.
I think that's right. We need to have
and also, you know, small miners can be solo mining, and
large miners should definitely be solo mining. That is the weirdest thing to me is you have miners with like
x a hash,
and they would be solving blocks a month, and yet they're still
on some FPPS thing. Is it only Mara that does that? I think so.
I think so. Mara is probably the the biggest miner that sold the mines. That's
Unknown: that's good. I mean, there's definitely others. There's, like, there's this one entity that keeps, like, showing up, you know, just unknown.
And then when you look at them and see their, like, mining
rewards, like the address that their mining rewards go to, you can see they've got, like, a long history
of
Bitcoin mining block rewards,
but you don't you have no idea who they are,
Unknown: where they are. Do they not have anything in the script SIG? Like, there's no tag?
Unknown: No. I'll
see if I can find one.
Unknown: I mean,
I guess if you're concerned
about
privacy,
right, you should change your script Sig like every single time. Like what benefit is there to like know who has solved all these blocks?
Unknown: Right.
Well, and you'd have to update your address too every time.
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: Which
I think they should be doing.
Unknown: Yeah, I don't see why not. Right? You could just sort of on regular interval change it, or I guess every time you solve a block, change it. So
Unknown: here, I'll let me copy this link from mempool.space,
and I'll put this in
the group chat here on Riverside.
So you should be able to see that. Hopefully, you can see my messages now.
Unknown: I can't see your messages,
negative?
Unknown: No. You don't see it? Mm-mm. Where'd you put it? Studio chat? Yeah. In the what the chat that Ryan was talking to us in.
Oh. It's the studio yeah. The studio chat. The live it says live Public chat.
Unknown: I do not see it. Oh, for fuck's sake.
Unknown: Dylan literally just replied underneath my
Unknown: is so Really? Nope. Not here. Here.
Unknown: I'll put it in the
Mine goes Damn it. Did you see mine? Yeah. I can see you guys are all replying underneath my message. This is driving me You're being censored, Eco. Yeah. You are.
Here. Let me I'm gonna put it in our signal chat for the
pod two fifty six.
Unknown: Ryan sees it. Wait. What?
Unknown: For any
yeah. There he goes. There you thanks, Scott. What is this, Link?
This is the unknown
minor or like one of
I'm assuming are several, but like,
you can see that they've had
well, I mean this is gonna be skewed because there's a lot of unknown minors. But like,
you can look at like some of their more recent block rewards, like just the first one, like nine twenty four, nine forty four.
Yeah. Like if you go in there and look at that and then look at the coin base reward,
you know, you can see in the, like, signature, it's just like a
Unknown: a string, you know, probably some That looks like a UUID to me, which is kind of interesting. If you wanted to, like, just
come up with a unique ID but randomize it every single time, a UID would be able to do it.
But
Unknown: then if you look at the address it goes to, so this address ends with TU6.
Yep.
And you go in there and you can see like the total received is, you know, they've received 368.9
Bitcoin
to that address.
So like, you know, this is no like
home miner.
Right?
Unknown: Yep. State actor. This is the feds.
Unknown: Well, maybe. But yeah, I mean
Unknown: I it makes sense. Right? Like what benefit is
is there for
someone to
claim their pool and and claim all their blocks? Right? I guess Street cred. Yeah. And and maybe like promotional
if you're trying to get more miners on your pool. But Right. I don't know why Bitmain doesn't just start putting in different script segs so that they
Unknown: appear Search to have shows less on them. Of dominance over the network.
Unknown: Right.
Unknown: Jeez.
Unknown: So addicting clicking through mempool
dot space.
Unknown: Well,
should we give a shout out to some of our hashers?
Unknown: Sure. Let me pull them up.
Unknown: While you're doing that, I am
getting closer to
opening up the HydraPool server that I'm running publicly.
Unknown: K.
Unknown: I'm not quite there yet. I screwed something up with the Prometheus
database
where
it's like lost
basically, it doesn't it doesn't supply Grafana with any of the data from Prometheus right now.
So I've gotta fix that, and I'll I'll be talking with Jungly tomorrow, and hopefully we can get that resolved.
But, basically, I've just got, like
like,
one or two steps left to document for my guide, and then I'll be posting that on the hydropool.org
website. Nice. And then I'll, like, open this up
publicly,
and then we can try and get our, you know, regular hashers to this show to migrate over to the new server.
And then this will begin our tests leading into the telehash
Unknown: next month. Now is this
hardcoded to go to
the donation address?
Unknown: Not at the moment, but it will be when I do the
telehash.
Nice. Now be well, before I open it up publicly,
it'll be hard coded so that, like, a 100% of the block reward will go to support the two fifty six foundation.
Now I
do have a second
identical
Optiplex ninety twenty that I've done all the exact same steps to.
And I think what I'm gonna do with that one is make it like the Bitcoin Park pool server.
So that like what they're doing with the space in Denver, like any members
can point hash rate to the Bitcoin Park
pool,
hydro pool instance.
And that one will be set up just to
pay out the rewards proportional to the hash rate contributed.
So I think I'm gonna do that. But then the hydro pull one for the two fifty six foundation,
you know, if you're pointing hash rate there, that's how you support
the foundation. So a 100% of that will go to the foundation.
Unknown: We'll plug that work into a pool checker.
Unknown: Yeah. Make sure. Yeah. What if there were home miners that wanted to,
like donate
ten, twenty, 30% of their hash rate to the two fifty six Foundation in perpetuity but they wanted some for whatever their heating set up or
is that something that could be done? You know where it's not full hash rate donation or it's like you get
Unknown: essentially a large pool fee? As far as I'm aware, that has to come from the client side, not the server side.
I mean, maybe there's a way to do it from the server side, but I don't
I don't know. Like, I think you'd have to, like, tell your
Unknown: How do the pool how do the pool's do it? Well, we could we could set it up so that the the pool takes a fee, but that wouldn't allow you to mine with a pool of your choice.
Right. Right. That's fair. If you if you wanna do, like, you know, mining,
you know, send 50% of your hash rate to
to 256
and then send 256 to Ocean to get your regular payouts or whatever from them. That would have to be on the mining on the miner side. Yeah. That's what I'm thinking. Yeah. There you go. Use Mugena to do it. Mugena's gonna support this. Yeah. Mugena would make this very easy. Mhmm.
I don't know. Does I think maybe some of the third party firmware does. I don't know. Does
I don't know if Bitmain firmware does.
Unknown: Oh, I don't know about Bitmain. I don't think so. But I know, like, the Brains OS
firmware does. I think Luxors does as well.
And I think
kaboom
Kaboomracks had a like, their own version of VNISH. So I I think maybe you can do it with VNISH and
Unknown: and the KaboomeraX version. I don't know. The new Nerd QX firmware allows you to do it as well.
Unknown: Oh, you can split it right in the
Unknown: That's cool. Yeah. You can split it percentage wise with the Nerd the new Nerd QX firmware. We don't have that on BidX yet, but it's also a little bit know what I really like? It's up. Yeah.
Unknown: I really like that the you could put a
two factor authentication
on there so that if anyone wanted to make changes to your NERD QX plus plus, they'd have to have your two FA code.
Unknown: Yeah.
Yeah.
Pmax has been doing some really amazing work with that firmware.
It's really cool.
Unknown: Crushing it. I love the interface.
Unknown: Alright.
On LingCoin, I'm gonna start shouting out our hashers.
Oh, this just freshly updated. Okay.
Pour one out for the two
RPIs I accidentally killed Raspberry Pis. Oh, no. Sad.
That is sad.
Shout out to Scott Offord from Open Hash Foundation, Schnitzel Fish Tank X, and Scott Offord from Bitcoin Mining World.
Those four contributors to LingQoin. Appreciate the the hash rate. Now I'm curious what happened to the RPIs.
Unknown: Yeah.
Set your miner up now with
what you did. We'll we'll check it next week.
Unknown: Yeah.
Who is that? Who's tinkering with Raspberry Pies?
On solo CKpool, shout out to Jeffrey Epstein did not kill himself. Tried and true. Schnitzel wall axe,
one.
Rock paper bitcoin.fm.
Boring worker name,
ocean pool is centralized in custodial.
Unknown: Yeah.
Told
you so.
Unknown: It's fine. Bid access, check your trees for signs of rot and decay. If they are near your house, tag your picks. Woodminer at on Primal. I hope Tyler reads this whole thing. Shout out to Woodminer. What a legend. Yeah.
Bitaxe three.
Bitcoin needs a decentralized pool.
Yes. And bitcoingunshop.com
site live soon.
Unknown: No.
Bitcoingunshopyeah.
Dot
Unknown: Let's see if that's live soon.
Unknown: Bitcoingunshop.com?
Unknown: That's what it said.
Yeah. Just all lowercase, all one word.
Doesn't seem to be live yet. I'm not getting anything.
All three of us immediately check.
Unknown: That sounds amazing. I don't know what the fuck bitcoingunshop.com
is, but make that a thing. It sounds awesome.
Unknown: Yes. We'll be following that closely.
But our
personal podcast FBI agent will not.
And shout out on public pool,
average bid ax office,
hardestblocks.org,
and Stalin's bid ax. Okay.
Unknown: Communism.
Woo hoo.
Unknown: And then on ocean, shout out to bible hodl.
Bidax Proof of print, bid ax one.
Serving bitcoin.com,
one. Anything you type, Stevens will read. It's true. Yep.
two. You stay classy San Diego.
And Reckless Systems, Geyser Fund Project Satoshi Starter.
Unknown: Alright.
Unknown: Zurka Sehash and Western Mass Bitcoin meetup, WinHydropool
eco.
Unknown: Soon.
I gotta
fix the database.
Unknown: Fucking Self hosting is fun.
Unknown: Yeah.
So
there was, like you know, I made a a folder called Hydropool,
and, like, I put the, like,
the
files in there to make HydroPool work. And
as I'm, like, getting ready to, like, open it up to the public, there's there's this thing you do to secure your server. So you, like, you
use your password and there's like a function that uses assault to like give you a hash
and you like put that hash in the configuration file
to like make it secure. Right? So like I did that.
But the file I need
one of the files I needed
wasn't there because I hadn't created it yet. And it was the Prometheus dot YAML file.
And
so
when I looked in the directory,
I did see an item called Prometheus dot YAML.
And so I tried to, like, sudo nano
that file so I could edit it and put the hash in there that I needed,
But
the system informed me that I couldn't run that command on it because it wasn't a file, it was a directory.
And I'm like, oh,
stupid me.
During one of my previous sessions, I must have accidentally created this
file
or tried to create a file, and I accidentally made it as a directory,
which is not hard to do on command line. Like, can you can accidentally create a directory when you meant to create a file. So I assume that's what had happened. I'm like, okay.
I'll so I, like, double checked. I went into this, like, Prometheus dot YAML directory
and double checked to make sure it was empty, and it was. I'm like, cool. We'll just go ahead and delete that shit. Don't need that. And now I'll create the Prometheus dot YAML file,
and I'll copy the contents from the
template in GitHub,
populate that, put in my hash, save that,
reboot everything, should be good to go.
And I go and check the Grafana website and like all the like data links are broken. Like Grafana's not getting any information. Were they hidden files?
I'm pretty sure it was like some kind of symbolic link that I
fucked up. I don't know. I have no fucking clue what I'm doing.
So
that's that's where I'm at. Jungly's gonna
bail me out tomorrow.
Unknown: I
Unknown: said, Jungly, fix this. Yeah. Help me, please.
Unknown: It's so funny. It's so true. Like,
being sovereign, self hosting,
doing everything right is awesome. And then you have little blips and moments like this where you're like, this is the worst thing ever. This sucks. I hate this.
It happened to me. We just got all of our SMTP
and IMAP records, like, blocked from
Proton that we were using for newsletters because we have dynamic IPs at the building. And I'm like oh, really? Oh. Yeah. Bummer. And then I found out our Internet service provider here doesn't offer static IPs, not even on their business tier anymore Mhmm. As of six months ago. So Bullshit.
Yeah, there's always little things, but it's really good learning experience. Yeah. What do you do? How do you fix that?
Right now, temporary, just paying an SMTP provider that doesn't
block static IPs. We're using SendGrid
to Are get the newsletters to
Unknown: you gonna start self hosting your own SMTP?
Unknown: Well, that's like the one of the options is run your own email. Right? But then you have to deal with reputation and everything.
Ryan
Ryan took on that burden, I think.
Unknown: Didn't you, formerly, Scott, run your own email server? I have. Yeah. For many years. It's it means that, like, no one on Gmail will just get your emails anymore. Exactly. It's lovely. Yeah.
No one uses Gmail though so it's fine.
Unknown: I just use Gmail.
Unknown: Why don't I just use Gmail?
Unknown: Says the guy that never reviews our Google Docs because he won't open Google Docs.
Unknown: Yeah.
Just use Gmail. It's fine.
Unknown: Do you use Nextcloud?
What do use for hide? What do you use for Docs, Iko?
Unknown: Usually just text files. Like a TXT file and I'll send it where it needs to go. It's like this. Like take this tree and you mash it up and like make it all flat and like
Unknown: write off. That's pretty hilarious. Like someone asks you for a resume or some important document and you're like, here's this text file.
Unknown: Here you go. Oh, no. I I convert like, I use
like for
that sort of stuff, like I use
LibreOffice.
Okay. It's
it's got all the same tooling like Microsoft Office does. Yeah. There's like a Word document application in there, and you can export PDFs
from that. So like,
you know, for a lot of the two fifty six Foundation paperwork and whatever,
I'm sharing
PDFs
and Word documents
just like
anyone else. But what I just avoid doing is
uploading it to a server
like
Google Docs
and working with it from there. I just don't like doing that.
Unknown: Yeah, I remember downloading Microsoft Office on a disk for the year. Right?
Unknown: Pre cloud was pretty nice. Those are the good old days.
Unknown: Now
everything's cloud.
Unknown: But, yeah, I did try
running Nextcloud.
And I, like, quickly became a full time
sys admin,
which was not my goal.
And, you know, after, like, two weeks of trying to get that shit to work and just not
succeeding, I abandoned the idea.
Unknown: The Ubuntu server,
like, installer
will install Nextcloud for you.
Unknown: Have you done it? Mhmm.
Unknown: It's like when you're you know, like, you get through your USB stick and you're gonna flash, you know, your PC with Ubuntu server. Like Yeah. Mhmm. When it's installing, it's like, you know, one of the things you can also install is Nextcloud.
Unknown: Yeah. I I saw that option. Did you did you do it and, like, use the Nextcloud?
Unknown: Were you happy with it? I did it and installed it, and I have not used Nextcloud. But We use it for all of our infrastructure at the space. It's been alright.
Unknown: The big problem I had was
there's like this I can't remember what it's called. There's like some, like, database tool that, like, that, like, lets you, like, edit documents
from
Nextcloud.
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: I
forget what that tooling is called, but I had a a very difficult time implementing that tool.
Couldn't do it.
Unknown: We've struggled with, like, the cloud interface for that, especially with multiple
users
for collaborative document editing, which kinda defeats the purpose. Exactly.
Unknown: Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Unknown: It was called like a Regis
database or something like that. I'm trying to someone in the chat probably knows.
Unknown: Favorite service that we've started self hosting that I'm pretty
happy with has been Discourse, which I use for heatpunks.org,
our community It
comes with a lot of good features. Like I really like it.
And I know that
Discord has been
a topic of contention with OSMU and stuff, Scott, but Discourse has been pretty cool. Yeah. That's cool. Discord sucks.
Yeah.
Unknown: I started looking and there's like, a Nostril based open source version called Flotilla that I started looking into. I don't know. Yes. Who's behind that? I think I had a chat with him. I forget his name. What's his name? He was in
Unknown: he was in He was at GBS.
Unknown: Yeah. GBS. That's right. Yeah. I'm blanking on that. Derek Ross?
Unknown: No. No. It wasn't Derek.
I don't think so.
But, yeah, it is a cool project. Yeah. Seems cool. Seems early, but Rockstar Dev.
Unknown: It wasn't Rockstar Dev.
Unknown: Would have remembered that one.
You look like a rockstar, Iko.
Unknown: No.
No. I'm just a just a random dude that likes Bitcoin.
Unknown: Yeah.
Unknown: Alright. Very nice. Did we go over everything? I think so.
Unknown: Thank you for the hashing.
Unknown: Alright. Yeah. Shout out to trash. Yeah. I mean, I've got a really full schedule here, so I'm gonna have to let you all go.
Who am I kidding?
I'm just fucking around.
But, no, it's been fun.
Unknown: Next week, episode 100,
Christmas Yeah.
Unknown: That's right. It is episode 100 next week. Christmas Eve episode 100. Be there. It's gonna be amazing.
Unknown: You should get Rod to come say, like, one nice thing or something. Yeah. He'll
Unknown: I'm trying.
He'll he'll be back.
Unknown: Good. And Gum will give us his blessing and then leave. Yeah. He'll he'll make an appearance one of these days.
Unknown: But
anyone who's still listening,
go to change.org/billandkioni.
Sign the petition to pardon samurai
because code is not crime.
Unknown: Do it. Do it now.
Unknown: Thank you.
Unknown: Thanks.
Unknown: See you all